Here's another example,
not as dramatic,
of creating a photo
illustration out of photographs.
But in this case, this
is also showing evidence
that you are fabricating
the pieces in your device.
This particular image is a CAD
image used by the researchers
to show their device showing
the various fabrications,
and this is how they used it
in their patent submission.
But this is done in CAD.
They also made a
picture of their device,
but you really
can't see very much
about their very
sophisticated ability
to make the various layers.
And so what I did was
I took that device
and separated it into
the initial pieces
that they did fabricate.
I laid them out on a
background and decided
to try to use these images
showing the layering of how
the device is made.
So out of these
images, I constructed
a photo illustration of
those pieces using software.
But these are real images that
you've just seen from before.
Here's another way of
showing it, making it
somewhat three dimensional.
But basically, this is
a photo illustration
of the layers of this
device not only showing
how it works (with the
right labeling of course),
but also showing that they did
indeed fabricate the layers.